[موسيقى]
في عطلة نهاية هذا الأسبوع في أوكرانيا ، اجتمع بضع
مئات من المدنيين للتحضير
لدورة تدريبية على الدفاع عن
أشخاص من جميع الأعمار ، لكن معظمهم من
الشباب الأصغر سنًا بالنسبة لنا ،
وكانت ناتاليا هنا مع ابنتيها
كالينا وحفية
هي  تخبرني أنها تتحدث معهم طوال
الوقت حول الحرب المحتملة مع روسيا ، نعم
نحن نتحدث دائمًا عن هذا عن الحرب
ولدينا خطة
[موسيقى]
لهذا السبب
نحن هنا التدريب الذي ينظمه
حزب سياسي يميني متطرف ويشرف
عليه الأوكراني
يجبر دفاع الحكومة الإقليمي
الأشخاص اليوم على تعلم
القتال باستخدام السكين اليدوي بالعصي باستخدام مسدسات خشبية
لممارسة الرماية حول الزوايا
في تدريب المجموعة التكتيكية على الهدف
والاستماع إلى كيفية التعامل مع
مفجرات البازوكا والألغام
كالينا البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات مع الانتباه عن كثب
أخبرتني والدتها أنها قلقة للغاية من
أنهم لن يغادروا في الوقت المناسب إذا كان هناك
غزو روسي كامل
لكن ناتاليا تقول إنها بقيت
لأنها جراح  وأنا أعلم أنك تريد البقاء
هنا لماذا
لأنني طبيب وأعتقد أنني أستطيع
مساعدة الناس
عندما
تأتي الحرب
إلى
وطننا وطنية ناتاليا رمز قوي
لوضعه هنا على تل عاصف فوق
مدينة لا في
هي وغيرها  الأوكرانيون أخذوا هذا
حرفيا
لا داعي
للذعر آرون بورنيت سي إن إن أوكرانيا